ceux qui s'apprêtent à voter jean luc
mélenchon qui mélenchon sait très bien
très bien
c'est très bien oui si au second tour
c'est une très très bonne vous allez
voter ce qu'il faut voter pour jean luc
mélenchon ou jean luc mélenchon n'est
pas notre adversaire nous on pense qu'il
ya toute une série de salariés de
chômeurs de jeunes qui ne se sentent
absolument plus représentés qui pensent
que tout ce système politique n'a rien à
voir mais annonce une danse avec la
candidature de philippe poutou ils ont
un candidat qui ne leur ressemble un
continent filiales comme eux un candidat
qui vit comme eux et ils ont la
possibilité d'utiliser ce moyen là
d'utiliser cette salle alors
diplomatique de vote utile
qu'est ce que vous allez faire contre ce
vote utile mais ne soit utile
kitty décide qu'à voter utile ou pas
utile le vol le vol et xhaka il est
utile si quand je le fais je pense que
ça correspond à ce que je voulais et si
ce que je voulais c'est dire
eh bien je veux rompre avec ce système
parce que ce système est responsable de
toutes les catastrophes qu'on connaît
qu'elles soient économiques qu'elles
soient sociales qu'elles sont
écologiques je veux voter pour quelqu'un
qui me ressemblent parce que je veux
enfin qu'on construise une
représentation qui parle d'en bas qui
partent de nous va je vote philippe
poutou et le vote utile par exemple hier
manuel valle a dressé il a adressé une
lettre à ses concitoyens notamment
d'evry on peut il ya que emmanuel macron
est le seul moyen d'éviter la
confrontation entre la droite et
l'extrême droite
ceux ci une forme de vote utile vous
êtes d'accord c'est que valse pense ça
puisque toute façon il soutient le
maquereau mais chacun va essayer de
vendre son propre vote comme étant le
seul vote utile et une grande partie de
ce vote utile se base non pas sur les
idées sur ce que je pense que lorsque
j'ai envie d'exprimer mes se base sur un
calcul de si je vote comme ça
je vais battre un tel qu'il ne sera pas
là et tant qu'un tel sera là en face
d'un tel jean luc tous ces gens là où
toujours parié sur le fait que marine le
pen serait au deuxième tour et que
l'important c'était de désigner qui
serait l'adversaire de marine le pen on
voit que les choses sont devenues mais
un tout petit peu plus compliqué pas au
deuxième tour selon vous mais écoutez on
verra on verra mais l'important c'est de
faire reculer les idées qui sont
défendues
il ne peine et ce qu'elle représente de
vie des gens les clients charlier
d'extrême gauche foot c'est à lui qu'il
faut le demander
oui mais il est donc vous avez vous avez
la réponse
mais là encore l'importance elle est ce
qu'il faut aller voter pour jean luc
mélenchon
ils vont voter contre l'extrême droite
de marine le pen contre la droite
extrême de fillon contre l'extrême
libéralisme de macron ils vont voter
contre le bilan du gouvernement est
globalement ou autres la halle
polyvalente et il prie tous les votes
pourquoi alors et votent contre tout ça
mais ils votent aussi pour un projet de
société qui a un projet de société
émancipateur quelle est la différence
avec le programme de nathalie arthaud
représenter qui nous pourquoi vous
n'avez pas réussi finalement à faire un
paquet de chips j'ose dire ou un ticket
avec nathalie arthaud parce que là vous
parlez de voter pour quelqu'un qui nous
ressemblent donc dans votre électorat
dans celui que vous ciblez pourquoi le
rapprochement avec nathalie arthaud n'a
pas été possible il ya un gâchis quand
même là non pour porter la voix que vous
voulez vous parler de ce que nous on
défend que je ne retrouve pas forcément
dans le dans le programme de nathalie
arthaud nous dit qu'on est
anticapitaliste au sens où le
capitalisme détruits évidemment les
conditions de travail des salariés dans
les entreprises le fait le chômage la
précarité mais pas que le capitalisme
c'est aussi la crise climatique puisque
cette crise climatique
elle est due à l'exploitation la
surexploitation des énergies fossiles
aux dégâts au dégagement des gaz à effet
de serre et c'est intimement liée à ce
système productiviste qui produit pour
conduire et pas pour satisfaire les
besoins pour nous la dimension
écologique non cohen ps est vraiment
longue essentiel absolument essentiel
est de la même façon on n'intègre pas
simplement ce qu'on va appeler
l'exploitation mais aussi l'oppression
l'oppression des femmes la situation qui
est faite aux femmes que ce soit au
travail évidemment un et 27%
le salaire de différence mais mais pas
seulement les postes dans lesquels on
est content cantonner le travail à temps
partiel
aussi le partage inégal des tâches qu'on
appelle les tâches domestiques les
tâches ménagères attaches familiales
parental et puis la question des
violences contre les femmes on pense que
tout ça c'est un système qui fabriquent
toutes ces violences et donc on pense
qu'on peut pas à séparer la lutte de
kells internat social de cette lutte
féministe paris